il se met kurtovitch historien
spécialiste de la nouvelle-calédonie
contemporaine bonsoir il se met kyoto
beach merci d'être avec nous premières
journées dont deux de rencontre entre
jean castex et c'est responsables
politiques de nouvelle-calédonie leçon
reçue pendant une semaine ça montre
l'importance que revêt ce dossier
calédonien pour le gouvernement français
oui à chaque fois les réunions à paris
sont très importants ils sont ce qu elle
est souvent en sommet le premier
ministre parfois le président de la
république et celle ci le sens
particulièrement puisqu'il s'agit
finalement de la dernière étape de la
sortie de l'accord de nouméa qui a
maintenant plus de vingt ans puisque
nous sommes face au troisième référendum
qui doit décider si oui ou non la
nouvelle calédonie va vers la pleine
souveraineté
alors que peut-on attendre de cette
semaine de discussions est ce que le
gouvernement peut renouer le dialogue
entre indépendantistes et loyalistes
nouveau possible oui le le dialogue n'a
pas vraiment cessé il a été renoué il y
a près de six mois lorsque monsieur le
cornu est venu à nouméa il a dû
d'ailleurs faire une quarantaine il a
réuni les principaux partis politiques
dans sur un îlot qui s'appelle le brédou
on appelle ça le groupe le pré ndour et
les échanges ont pu être
avancer et on est là dans une continuité
à paris mais une continuité avec des
difficultés nouvelles qui sont dues à la
conjoncture politique et économique en
nouvelle calédonie c'est sylviane et moi
vous dit le dialogue n'a jamais été
rompu ça dépend pour qui
par exemple l'union nationale pour
l'indépendance à lalinde et de courant 1
du fln et qui s annonçait qu'elle ne
répondrait pas cette invitation du
gouvernement pour quelles raisons oui en
fait les indépendantistes traverse une
mauvaise passe
comme a dit l'un d'eux ils ne se parlent
même plus alors qu'ils devraient se
parler puisqu'ils ont la majorité dans
le gouvernement élu et ils n'arrivent
pas à s'entendre sur une politique
commune au sein de ce gouvernement et
une répartition des responsabilités donc
nous sommes avec un gouvernement qui
expédie les affaires courantes
ensuite de ça il y a eu des événements
violents dans la de cette année sur
terre coutumière que ce soit sur la
grande terre aux îles loyauté
il y a eu les difficultés liées à la
reprise de de l'usiné de vale dans le
sud
malgré que les indépendantistes étaient
des unis sur cette question il y a eu
des des conflits des difficultés entre
les salariés de l'usiné et l'extérieur
et ensuite la politique minière en
province nord et fait l'objet de
discussions de contestation entre les
deux principaux partis indépendantistes
ce qui fait que ça à traiter ça a créé
un contexte qui a fait que l'uni panika
a préféré ne pas venir à paris plus le
fait que le document de l'état apparu
quand même nécessaire de prendre plus de
temps pour y répondre et pour en
discuter de la part de l'uni palika et
de l'union progressiste mélanésienne
alors lors des derniers
référendum
les indépendantistes étaient largement
majoritaires et puis ça s'est un petit
peu serré les lors des dernières
consultations est ce qu on peut
clairement parler aujourd'hui de moments
charnières à la proche de cette
troisième consultation sur
l'indépendance oui le moment est
charnière parce que monsieur le cornu a
innové en somme
en demandant à l'administration de
l'état de travailler dans le détail sur
les conséquences mais pour l'état d'une
accession à l'indépendance je vais dire
classique de la nouvelle calédonie et
c'est ce que vont faire les élus
calédoniens à paris ils vont balayer
secteur par secteur et aussi thème par
thème
damon et le droit le nickel toutes les
conséquences pour le pays d'une
accession à la pleine souveraineté qui
est finalement la question principale
qui est posée au référendum donc là cet
aspect pour ce référendum pour ce
travail politique est plus important que
pour les deux premiers et on le doit à
monsieur lecornu clairement dans
l'hypothèse d'une indépendance s quel
nouvel état cherchera à conclure des
traités notamment de partenariats
d'associations vous venez de le citer il
ya d'énormes richesses en nouvelle
calédonie et c'est compliqué on imagine
pour le gouvernement français d'y
renoncer aujourd'hui c'est une question
qui qui est débattue ce qui se passe
c'est que les indépendantistes ont
toujours dit qu'il y aurait un
partenariat privilégié avec la france
mais la question c'est de savoir si les
exclusives le degré de cette exclusivité
et la profondeur de ce partenariat c'est
ça fait l'objet d'ailleurs de plusieurs
questions que l'état pose au mouvement
indépendantiste
merci beaucoup il se met kurtovitch oda